uh you have to be like well balanced  with what you think what you feel and  what you love and then you can think  about longevity and I think for short  distance it's a different thing but for  long distance  I think it's a I think it's the best  approach to be well balanced and to to  enjoy what you do every day I think it's  very very important for me even for me  and I was able to win some big Ultra  race it's take me 10 years to to do it  in so 10 years is not nothing so I'm  sure we can do it in four five six years  but yes four or five six years for  people it's too long 100 my race is not  nothing and if you consider it like okay  it's just one word by mice race you say  I can do it so I will do it in one year  now I think it's not the good approach  100 with my race it's not nothing and if  you think it's nothing  it will be too hard for you